good morning
hello
good morning
we're here baby
what's up pascal
how are you
up shane
farmer good morning good morning good
morning
that means we're live baby
missing credentials i like it i like it
what's up trey volcano manor yay or nay
like you want to go there
or
if you like it or not
if i like it or not
i i like volcano manor it's sick
hello hello all welcome
welcome
what the guidance of the pitchfork
lead us forever onward and beyond we
need to get going man this this this
completionist run is going to take so
freaking long if we don't like have
longer streams so that's playing today's
kind of stream for a while we'll see
though
i am there just dying a lot
are you dying to the snaky boys
i don't know what you'd be dying to
well there's a lot you can die too
so cassium what's up dark knight good
morning everybody
okay let's check out
where what bosses we need to do so we've
got we've pretty much done everything in
limb grave
how'd the pga go it was actually sick
it's a really good tournament
justin thomas came back from i think he
was seven back and he wound up winning
let's go ian very nice very nice very
nice
gideon off near uses a normal staff of
karya
doesn't he have his own staff he has the
all-knowing staff
i believe
where is this
the watchdog storm foot whoops
no well we found patches but we can't
kill patches because we have to
do his quest line
so i couldn't kill him
so i don't want to check him off yet
now we can either go
to the learning of the lakes
i think that's really the next place we
should go
thank you solid snake
what's up kyle
i can't even replay this game without
getting so bored i don't find the game
boring so
that helps a lot to the east of
stormfoot
gate grace really
here
[Music]
oh wait never mind why are my runes
there
the scion i don't think we can get to
yet until
we can get to the teleporter
yeah
i don't know oh i can always do this
you said storm flip
my cute dog gets subs or gets tele tummy
rubs every sub yes
is it storm foot catacombs
was waiting for your stream for almost
two hours on the background but youtube
only started it now i did just start so
yeah
we've done every boss in limb grave
almost
i'm looking for archery burial watchdog
the storm foot one
i don't want to rub your tummy but i
will
if you really want me to
yeah i think
we're we're pretty much gonna probably
rebuild our entire build whenever we
beat ranala
and let me look up where this is
and i'll just have chat choose what they
want right now we're just kind of
getting through the game
did i kill the storm foot
bird tree
burial watchdog
[Music]
storm foot catacombs
yeah i did didn't i
i did too
but it looks like i died
i'm going over here and seeing what's
going on
took me three hours to farm that damn
sword oh by the way the reason that i'm
naked is because i'm giga chad and i
look cool
uh but also
blue dancer charm raises attack power
with a lower equipment load
just so you know not running around
naked
for no reason
yeah i definitely did this right
ooh
yeah we did we did okay cool
i just didn't check it off gotta check
gotta check
check
can't do the scion can't do patches so
we've we're done with lim grave
huge
big poggers
i'm gonna let chat choose where we go
next
lakes
caled
hell i could go to volcano manner if you
guys want i know a secret way
you need a reason to run around naked
you know what i didn't i didn't i didn't
need to say that did i
why do you guys want me don't don't say
caleb bro i know i don't even know why i
asked
because you guys are just gonna say
kayla
okay some of you saying lakes
i think we should go lakes enough of
your sane lakes for me to say okay let's
do lakes
i've already been lakes technically
let's go legs let's go lights thank you
you guys are very different from twitch
chat usually twitch chat would be like
go to the capitol right now lol you'll
die a lot
and you'd be right
just say that
youtube is more smart
i really want this though
there we go
your mood is too good to be ruined by
caleb
i like caitlyn
i think it's low-key beautiful
for how disgusting it is
let me jump off my horse
i'd be the only one to tell you where to
go if you were on twitch
yep
i'd have one viewer on twitch and it
would be uh it'd be kyle
okay
well
sheesh there's a lot we can do out here
huh
we can go talk to
gamer posture girl
why not go to the capitol
i don't think it's such a good idea
right now
i like caleb you're a grade six
misogynist
listen dude
caleb is really hard
but it is pretty
hello in its own way
hello
please
over here
yo what up girl hello
it's rather chilly here isn't it yeah i
don't have any clothes on so i would
know an errand
but i was accosted by a ruffian ooh
should we go four belfries
kill
that thug made off with a precious
necklace we do need to go see selling
because i found her
her real body you're right who
is tarnished
if you've any qualms confronting you
good point
i shall find another
what's up justice how you doing
i'm wearing the same outfit
what a blessing that we've met like this
the thug should be resting at an
abandoned home down the way
please
i must have the necklace back
okay
i remember running around for an hour
trying to find this place my first
playthrough and it's literally just
right over here
oh wait the death bird's gonna spawn
here isn't it
son of a [ __ ]
alright let's go
i missed
okay dude
i forgot that's a grab attack man
oh god
what's the lore on the death birds
they're annoying that's the lore
they're annoying and they suck there's
your lore
my least favorite enemy to fight in this
game
death birds death rights
can you do america's
what
oh yeah yeah
he does say that
yeah hold on he does say america's tits
you guys know if torrent uh the glitch
to get torrent to fly still works i
really doubt it still works that was
like over a month ago
america's tits you must be hungry
what are you looking at you're trying to
start some of me
this guy goes on reddit doesn't he ah
that necklace what you're after is it
[Music]
well
show me
what it's worth to you
and i'll consider parting ways with it
i'm not in love with it or nothing
you're a shrewd one chief i'll just buy
it first
you hand me the runes
and don't try nothing neither
thanks man all right
take it things no dumb use to anyone
anyway your bloody idea mate
don't cry have i talked to kenneth yet
because we need to go get the deck this
medallion as well oh piss off
what is it now
oh
i see
you want some of me prawn
yeah i didn't think that glitch still
works
all right then
it's yours
if you can meet me price
i could be persuaded to sell you some
other bits too
if you've got the runes
this guy's voice actor is sick
i'll buy one of those why not about ryan
oh
so you met the girl did you
all right well
sod the particulars of the mata but it
ain't my fault she's stupid enough to
get duped is it yo facts facts
she ain't alright that one lucky she
ain't died on the bloody roadside i
reckon
you're tarnished too ain't you
can you see it then
the guidance of grace i mean
i can't see it at all no more makes no
bloody sense anyway
my son no name [ __ ] like me should
get called to the lands between
cruel bloody joke you asked me
maybe something went tits or with it
maybe he's been broke for a good long
time
the urgery i'm saying not really like
hmm
that's interesting to think about
how like
it could just be completely broken maybe
that's why everything went south i don't
know
never met someone with a taste for
broncos trying to get him to say
america's tits
i'll be seeing you
i think he says it if i if i ask him now
america's tits
you must be hungry
i love that dude okay let's go back
america's tits you must be hungry
oh you guys hate the dung eater
yeah he's pretty freaking awful i'm not
gonna lie
he's about as bad as it gets as a as a
person
yeah you didn't know that worked
yeah
america's tits the thug should be
resting at an abandoned home down the
way
please
i must have he says the thing
let's go
oh yes
that is my missing necklace you're
welcome
can you reimburse me for the thousand
runes it costs myself
i am raya
in the service of lady tanith of the
volcano manor
i seek stalwart tarnished
in our house
you are very brave yourself
not only a steady hand
she helps us get the volcano manner
really fast
even to your own kind
such strengths it's worth doing this
precisely we need to do it anyway
please
take this
thanks
brave tarnished
seek the altus plateau the realm of the
earth tree
most tarnished are doomed to wander the
outskirts of the lands between
peering wistfully at the towering earth
tree but you are no ordinary tarnished
and once that is proven
the volcano manner will fully extend its
invitation
to fight
amongst a family of champions
lit
okay
i feel like
um
we need to do the deck this
because that's like the easiest way to
get into volcano manners over here
well
man
what's what's easier because i don't
know is volcano manor
or the academy easier chat
i think the academy's easier right
we could just go to the academy
to be honest
yeah academy's easier i yeah i was
tripping on that one okay
we're gonna do that
volcano manor can really
the manor can be really bad
sometimes
oh god i'm dead
stay there
okay we're fine we're fine
oh
oh now we're dead serpentine
stay over there
he's a sniper all right we're good
did you buy george martin's explanation
that he didn't name the bosses with grm
on purpose
um
i don't believe anything that man says
i don't believe anything that guy says
have you killed the gods apostle in this
playthrough
uh not yet we have not been to the altas
plateau yet
we should go to the dragon
because that's faster
well actually
i didn't get the map yet which is the
whole reason i came over here
all right i got a system for this area
just hold your horses all right
i have a system
very fast very efficient
okay ready for this
you guys gonna be blown away
run through here
grab these smithing stone threes
just one of them i guess
jump up here
go through the port
takes you right to the gate
i'm telling you i got this
okay
go up here
hit this bad boy
and we're gonna grab
some more smithing stones over here
boom another smithing stone three
go over here
down by this crabby boy
smithing stone two
oh yeah i do not plan on going to caleb
right now
you guys almost made me though okay now
we're gonna go
back up here actually
this might not be faster but i don't
care
then
we're gonna go this way we're gonna jump
onto that
we're gonna avoid the bear
this bears are cringe
i am speed
i'll i'll solo it on
get some smithing stone twos
and we're gonna go this way
wait you can do volcano manor easier if
you haven't beaten radon
uh
we're just gonna do the academy
we're gonna go to the four belfries and
kill the scion though
all right what is the percentage chance
that i can beat this dragon
give me a percentile
what did i get stuck on
owned
okay i can't get to him though
annoying annoying
i'm the best
kind of good at this game
do you sweep
owned
oh yeah
okay
oh
oh god
we gotta go
we gotta go we gotta go
okay good
do that i like it
i like it
i like it
hmm
what are you doing okay he's just
running away he's gonna do fire
yep
um can't do two there okay okay
go for the wing
whoa
well that was easy
all right
we're pretty good at this game aren't we
we're pretty good at this game
give me that key
are you gonna use dragon spells i don't
know yet
we can you know we can always use
ronaldo to make any build that you guys
want
south to north is progression caleb is
side quest level 100 should be a ride
around players in caled really level 100
hmm
maybe
i feel like i'm definitely beating radon
before level 100.
like well before
because i would say melania is like
level 120
and radon's way before
melania
what's the best weapon in your opinion
uh rivers of blood
thousand percent rivers of blood
oh yeah common players should probably
be level 100 but for most
i mean
depends on your skill level so who knows
yeah i wouldn't say radon's really all
that hard
[Music]
he's cool though
he can be hard if you don't know what
you're doing though obviously
nerd
where's the boar for belfries i don't
even know where i'm going right now
isn't it up there oh i'm stupid
we're gonna go over here for now
let's go meet eg
i think he can upgrade our weapons
die
godric and ranala radon reichard morgot
malacath millennium moog
yes
i believe you're right
godric and ronald are definitely the two
easiest
chard bears
[Music]
oh yeah we're gonna we're gonna meet
ronnie eventually here for sure
oh i do want to get that talisman from
eg very true
if he's got it
been binging all your lore videos
absolutely love them i'm glad you do man
that's great to hear
i'm still trying to cut like think of
the next one but i just thought i'd take
a break for like a week and just stream
well
look at you
we don't receive many visitors
i presume you are i love your voice eg
what brings you here
i like how he just stops talking to you
when he when he asks you that for some
reason
it's hardly my place to ask is it
i am eg
a blacksmith who once served the carion
royals yeah i did do bloods quests
who refuses to retire is rusty hammer
so here i am
still quietly plying my trade
on this spot i'm gonna let chad decide
the build damon
for the most part these bones are old
but still able
i have to come here just because vati is
slow
okay
that's mean
you saying you wouldn't watch my videos
please take care oh watch out there
ivanti was faster
i lose sights of all else
if you come too close good logical about
you man um
i am after all terribly large compared
to you tarnished you are a big boy you
know how hard it is not to break
anything while i work
thought brave tarnished
a word of warning if you please i just
like listening to him talk country once
belonged to the karyan royal family
should we do a radon build beyond this
that'd be sick when the raya lucari
academy turned on the carrions the
knights of the cuckoo descended on this
track of the cuckoo after leveling it
they carried on to the manor the karyans
were taken off guard
but their strength had not waned and
they repelled the knights onslaught
by conjuring an enchanted snare that
remains potent to this day
that is why i say tarnished radonbuild
could be fine don't go near the manor
unless you wish to lie with the corpses
of the heedless knights of the cuckoo
light semi live actually did that did he
quite a rare occurrence for such a
guarded soul as he
perhaps he sensed something unusual
about you
why do you wear a helmet
if you're friendly with blithe
i've something else not sure
lowers fp consumed by skills
that's big bro that's a big boy talisman
right there
that's that's uh that's a big boy
talisman right there
oh yeah dude okay
star scourge
star scourge jake
that'd be kind of fun
i was one who posted the theory on your
discord love your content and have
enjoyed hearing you speak about
something you seem to truly enjoy
this your first souls game bloodborne
next enjoy bloodborne man bloodborne is
a treat
i would say bloodborne is one of the
harder souls games so good luck
i don't want to go in there yet do i
what was i going to do we were going to
go to the four belfries that's right
that's right that's right that's right
that's right that's right that's right
that's right that's right
bhati probably being slow on purpose to
give other channels a chance just a
guess though
uh i have no idea i just i he gets
millions of views of video he doesn't
need to like make more than one video a
month
it the fact that he only uploads once a
month or maybe twice a month is it makes
his videos very special when they come
out
very special
look at this guy look at this headless
guy look at you
i stayed for the sassy chat
chat is sassy
but they're fun
we like sassy
in arc deck strength also just got to
melania first playthrough it's gonna be
a long day
yeah that's gonna be real [ __ ] hard
man so good luck
why no armor i have a talisman that
makes me stronger without any armor on
which one takes me back to uh the scion
at the chapel of anticipation it's not
this one i think this one takes you to
pharah missoula
think
[Music]
i need to look into these
the last one to the left
this one
oh they tell me don't they
haha
good job chat
good stuff boys
and girls
what a chat room what a great chat room
at least torrent no
oh we can go see nafeli we can
could do that
hey yo what up cup
hey yo come here bro
unfair and stupid
stop
that is just crazy and i'm dead okay
good
fantastic
these guys are quite good
spider
did i say it right
been taken to the spider
pretty much do you have to heal every
hit
ooh turtle talisman is not a bad idea
no i want to be strong
i don't know why i keep trying to use
torrent
the spider
it's a spider
nerd
yeah i feel like rolling to his right is
the right play
i rolled your dom
what is this
oh he's buffing
i keep rolling back for some reason
nerd
you're dead
okay
it's quite a lock when you think about
it
okay what what can we see up here i've
only been here like one time before
i don't remember
should i put some clothes on
i don't have to be naked
and the second monitor playing elderly
on the side and joining up good
good time after work thank you brother
oh that's pretty nice of you man thank
you romney
glad i could
entertain you somewhat
also it's it's straight up just the same
place okay
guys this was my maiden she's dead
though
pain
my maiden
all i can see is the crack of your ass
is there another door in there
any plans for a camera
um you guys want to see my face
it's like my face
go to the right of the chapel
oh
thank you
this is why i need you guys
whoa what oh okay
ashes of hawk which heeds no summons
revered by all others as sovereign back
in the days when stormville's wins still
raged like no other this ancient monarch
is proud however refusing to answer
anyone's summons
whoa
yeah i think a camera would ruin your
immersion
i think my voice is enough
is it nafeli time
we go see no feli
i bet
i bet
okay she's not here
why okay
so is she already out by the lake
in the village
oh he's here because i haven't talked to
them yet
i have talked to them
no she talks too much okay
i missed something come on bro
really
really did
like there's something else there
there's another ass summoned back at the
church
well frigg
i'll go get it
elbozo
you guys are better at exploring than me
just like go go go go go
and y'all are like no no no no
we talk about these skylines
kind of nuts
are you on xbox i'm actually on my nokia
phone
playing and streaming from it
no i play on pc
jkjk
back through the same door inside the
church there's a test okay thank you
i didn't walk through there because i
was like oh i bet that just leads to the
to the church
again
but this is the upper part
haha
stormhark dana
i've got dana
action remains in which spirits yet
dwell
uses summon dana then then then dean
his name's dean
spirit of the fierce hawk that
faithfully
rendered lifelong service to the old
king of storm mail long ago when the
true storm raged its cries emboldened
its fellows in battle in the
tempest man
and pestius wins that hit circle it
shred through foes
god some words in this game i have to
like look up on google translate and
have the lady like tell me how to
pronounce it because i just can't
[ __ ] read sometimes dude
i'm also dyslexic so that doesn't help
either
well cool
we're just doing all bosses and quest
lines i don't think we want to try and
get every single thing in the game
we could try
though you can use your own dead maiden
down under
brevari's quest
is that how we know that vary killed our
maiden
tempestuous tempestuous
tempestuous
what's your favorite build mine's been a
bleed build
uh rivers of blood and
what's the
what's the sword that that's like the
meteor sword
i think i want to do a radon build that
sounds sick
you are maidenless
yeah i think i only like it
because
it's really good
it's not confirmed i didn't think so
ruins greatsword is really good
as well
i think i'm gonna put some clothes on
yeah
yeah meteor ore
i don't think it's that one though
i get a lot of things mixed up
all right let's see how we're doing here
it's not bad
freaking wizards dude
yeah i think the theory that vary killed
our maiden is extremely strong but we
don't know for sure
ah
unfair
nice
the baby baby rattle weapon
i don't know what that is
i thought that was ronnie's dress no not
yet
you should do a faith build because
faith in general is kind of op with
things like frenzied flame blasphemous
misplayed
we'll see you'll see
we'll see what you guys want to do we'll
get we'll we got to progress to the game
a little bit more to even have those
options
so
and then we can always change around our
specs
get away from me
all right so how many of you guys know
that you can get to volcano manor from
the academy
raise your hand if you knew that
go there right now if we wanted
to
yep just gotta get abducted by virgins
calm down doggy
yeah pat just tells you that
we're not gonna do that though
that's why i like i like watching play
throughs myself anton
you can learn a lot of stuff from
somebody else's playthrough
yeah you have to get captured by the
iron maiden
we're running to the dog
i don't like this area
we'll come back
[Music]
ow
everyone loses their minds
dang it
oh
i should have used that to heal big time
come on
nice
come on dude
there we go
first try first try
thanks for the kind words words man i'm
i'm happy you like the lore videos
yeah guys just don't get hit smile
then it's easy
is this your first playthrough yeah
i have like five hours in this game
i think i'm pretty good at it
i like you kyle
you missed two secret doors i'm sure i
did
we'll come back
trying to beat the bosses
balls
does that take you to turtle boy i think
it does
we got to beat this guy though this guy
oh
i might die to this guy
because he can parry the living [ __ ] out
of you
well
like i said
i know you can make them fall in the
elevator
i just didn't want to cheese
but now i'm gonna cheat
this game is too big for me to play as
it as many times as i have the other
souls games
this game is very large
but it's also one of the best games i've
ever played so i don't mind playing it a
lot you know i mean
i'm good to elin how are you how about
you how you doing
what day is it today
it's monday
right
all right we cheesing
[Laughter]
nice perry idiot
oh that timing was incredible
oh man
that was very lucky
very very lucky
why does my character look so like he
looks matt
like matt gray
he's just smiling
[Laughter]
why do we stop laughing
hush
little culver mommy
i'll soon birthday anew
a sweeting
fresh
and pure
she is bat [ __ ] nuts chat
bat [ __ ] nuts
come here
sleep tight
sleep tight
and we gotta do another round
no i ain't dying to furniture
i ain't dying to a chandelier dog
are you kidding me
this fight is really cool
[Music]
probably the best music one of the best
osts
i love the music here
[Music]
what happens when you get cucked by a
ginger
you become ranala
quite literally become ronaldo
whoever said ronald is flat chested i
want you to look
at her butt i want her to look at your
at her butt
kind of nuts no fear
i will hold thee
patience
ye will be countless born
forever
upon my name is ronnie the witch
yeah you guys notice that you can see
like ratagon's butt crack i shall not be
disturbed by thee
foul trespasser
send word
far and wide
it always lags there so bad
of the last queen of karya
granala of the full moon
what do you guys think is the most
what's your favorite boss fight in this
game i'm very curious what y'all think
this fight's gorgeous second i think
first phase is gorgeous too second face
is beautiful as well
a moon boy right off the bat bro
okay
oh sh
wow
okay
i died so fast
okay we need to put our armor back on
wow that killed me in an instant
morgot is why friends don't let friends
simp
oh i can do polls on youtube hold on
which four i should do like the four big
ones right
or how many can i do let's see ad option
ad option i can only do four options
best fight
question mark
let's do uh
malakath
melania
moog
radon
for now
ask your community
you guys see that yeah there it is
sleep tight
and tight
you guys see the voting thing oh yeah
you can
radon is currently winning i should swap
out the talisman as well that's true i'm
gonna let that go for the next fight
uh yeah
raises defense when hp is low maybe
oh boost magic damage negation we should
do that
all y'all are voting for radon dude
i agree radon's my favorite fight in the
game
yeah i'll do another poll i'll do
another poll
um i'm going to keep the eg talisman on
because
i use less fp when i do my um
unsheathed skill
should i do
like next poll should just be like uh
is godskin duo a good fight yes or no
i feel like i know what the answer will
be
are they already hiding bro
uh
[Music]
a little bleed
ow that hurts
oh you're right here
weird
[Music]
i'm surprised malaka the vote's so low
that's surprising
it's probably based on the options
right
i can only do four
[Music]
i knew i'd staggy
what happened to my physic oh it didn't
work
leave me be
really
okay
there's still another wolf in here bro
wow dude
wow i just got bodied
oh i don't have enough health for this
do i it's clearly doable though
48 hours in and i haven't fought
everyone
uh you it's not even close you need
hundreds of hours trey to fight everyone
in this game
i just got bodied again bro
all right what's the next poll
while i run back
so radon won that one
i'll do another one
i like pulse
um
best fight
i'll put radon
in
with
class
uh do sacks
um
and then what was he what was the other
good one
melania
i'll just do that
oh god free
yeah yeah yeah yeah
godfrey
radon placidusax melania godfrey
i vote god i vote like
gosh
that's tough that's tough pull
mogu does got the drip but nobody voted
for him earlier
madeira is a terrible boss worst dragon
fight they ever did
dude i'd love madeir
madeira was such a good fight
let's try this again
i don't have a lot of health for this so
we'll do our best
the first elden lord
i'm good joe how are you
godfrey's grab attacks are pretty cool
favorite boss in all swords born
soulsborne games
ishin from sekiro 100
that is the best fight ever
you kidding me
stop throwing books at me man
we're throwing books at me man
that's a big bleed right there
[Music]
i rolled
i probably had no stamina
oh
so radon's gonna win again huh
[Music]
have you guys played sakiro
oh priscilla that's an interesting one
really
[Music]
you mean the most recent god of war
i played it
wait running away
[Music]
nice
that's big
bigger than it seems
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she may not summon
i can't believe i even got hit by that
that's pain
nice
she didn't even summon
my dear let's
into
go
weave thy night
into being
great rune of the unborn
next poll favorite from soft npc oh man
i wouldn't even know how to like start
that
my sweetings
come out from whence you hide
there are books and light a plenty
did the knots
pinwheel's the best fight ever
or will he be gravestones
to be better born a new
so b-bats up on i knew
oh i got a good pull i got a good one i
got a good one hold on
so what what was this one
everyone except radon was close so
that's that's not bad
let's do all right i'm not even going to
tell you which the
what this one is
okay wait
this might be hard
this could be split
all right check that one
holes look good on youtube
i like it
it's not gonna be as close as i thought
is it
oh i got four yeah
two it doesn't matter just put it in the
bigger and we can change it
oh all y'all like ronnie huh i mean dude
she's a doll
we like ronnie though where did he flee
my sweeting shut up
thou
is it thy wish to be born anew
to become a sweeting
reborn of
[Music]
[Music]
i would birth thee
as a sweeting
fair and fine
fair and fine
okay
yeah i should say rena
or ranala
rena or ronnie
okay okay okay okay
well good job guys we'll be rinalla good
stuff good stuff let's let's check our
list here
let's check it all right where the hell
even are we right now we beat the scion
we're pretty much done with lim grave
we have beat
ranala queen of the full moon we beat
ratagon's red wolf
um
we died to the death bird lol
don't even know what that is oh wait yes
i do i do know where that is
i do
oh these are gonna be hard to find
okay
where should we go next
i want that checklist check the
description
check the description
your kind are all of a piece
down bad
emboldened by the flame of ronnie's arms
omen killer next oh we need to go to
nephili that's what we're going to do
we're going to go to nephili
which is like
under
this area
ronnie's real corpse has red short hair
yes she short red hair yes she does we
don't know if it was short
um but it got burned off
so yeah
here i'm gonna end this poll because
ronnie
clearly is the winner
y'all are down bad for ronnie huh
shut up oh i want to hit him
blight is your one true love
all right this one's gonna be tough
hopefully no one nope he's following me
hold on i got another pole
this one will actually be hard
oh my god
nobody's safe out here
she does have a very cool character
design
along with everybody else in the game
not gonna not gonna cap with you
all right
i don't think you guys might struggle
with this one
that'll be the last bowl for a while
unless i want to do it again
eg or blood
can't do polls from your phone why can
you not do anything from your phone on
youtube
you clicked blind didn't you
but you meant eg
i use a controller
really
i love eg dude
what a sick way to vote
stop crying
stop crying
yeah kyle i just i think you don't know
how to use your phone
because i think other people are using
their phone
i don't even know who these people are
guys why isn't a fellaini not here what
what do i need to do
where is nafeli
every time i come through here she's
here but she's not
she should be right there
oh you meant create a poll
yeah
stop
[Music]
nerd
she's in stormville i mean i've already
been there
now we got pot boy
but i've already been there
let me go to the round table
no we
nefeli helps us with the omen killer
man blind won by a lot
i wasn't even close she's not here
do i need to talk to gideon
allow me a word of advice
as your senior now she's definitely been
there before i've gotten a medallion 100
nothing more
a house guest
yet to earn their keep
remember your place
newcomer i don't think she goes to the
basement until gideon tells her that she
doesn't need her anymore
but i will check
i do think gideon has to be in his study
i i think you're right
there's nothing left to say
be at your leisure
yes we killed godric
okay now he's over here perfect
dong eater or raya
hey
there's no fellaini lou
you again it's no phil leaves to the
round table
i'm glad to see you here
i have something for you i found it in
godric's grafting grounds
you defeated him
you should have it make good use of it i
don't intend to make a habit of
scavenging corpses i wouldn't think so
thank you very much
ah yes
i wonder if you've met my foster father
he's in his study
the room enters guarding just over there
if you haven't already
i advise you introduce yourself
father is leader of the roundtable
i'm sure talking to him will be worth
your while
okay mommy
hey yo what you want what do you want
that's what i said
okay do i need to talk to him probably
receive the wisdom of the two fingers
have you not
then i bit you welcome
as a true member of the round table
blind one by elements
of landslide
dude who wishes to stand before the
elden ring and become elton lord
i am accumulating knowledge
to be
all knowing yeah yeah yeah
gideon
as such
i ask that you remain constant
ah
my mouse is off the screen okay
let's see
i got another one you guys seem to like
poles
all right this one will be weird
who's
more evil
who's more evil
gideon or the dung eater
okay
alexander's evil
okay now we should be able to go to the
village
and she should be there
yeah eg kinda got messed up bro i ain't
gonna cap eg got
eg got
absolutely destroyed at the end
there she is
oh
it's you
well
what do you make of it
what's happened to this village
is the site much the same tiger ball
oh god of the week
murder and pillage unchecked
a waking nightmare
made by men
but this time
i'm a woman grown
and though the suffering cannot be
undone
yeah dung eater
he is evil incarnate
i think gideon has
ambitions
that make him seem evil to us
and he treats us that way this time but
uh i'm a woman grown dog eater is just
straight up cannot be undone
pain still meet out justice
justice to the oppressors justice stars
remind them
i am nephili lou
warrior warrior all right let's go kill
an omen together
let's go killing omen
omen killer
not an omen
get away from me
this is a jump i don't know why i did
that
i wanted to look cool
that's you
it's you justice
it's you
let's go no fellaini lou
bye bye
okay
patches through celibace oh god
we'll resume the polls
who's she getting hurt by
well this is bad
maybe i went a little far there
this man slaps
wow
okay
jesus that i've never been hurt by that
guy so much
he's never done that much damage to me
that blood loss though
i mean
[Music]
i mean
hey dog eater barely won that one though
that's a good pull
that's a good one
is it weird i like godric fight more
than godfrey no i don't think that's
weird
i did kind of get on there getting this
dog out of here bro
hey you rent
oh there's another dog
dude i'm in a tree
oh now we got
yeah you're done
you're done
dude i love slowly the witch's channel
you can talk about other channels in
here i don't care
zolly the witch's channel is awesome
she like hacks the game to find cool
stuff it's really cool
um i think there's another fight up here
as well it's a it's an evergill
i i think godric is an s to your fight i
might be weird for saying that but i
think godric's an s to your fight
it's it's pretty easy but just like
the voice acting in it the like area you
fight him in his move set the music in
it like bro it's it's so cool
joy is way cuter
way cuter dude
esther
thanks for becoming a tarnish man i
appreciate that
thank you very much
welcome to the agency
the game's lagging
okay
yeah he's he's like a spectacle
this is aiden huh
or adon
okay ow okay ow okay ow
what some fire giant [ __ ] bro
he's so chunky
my man can heal
[Music]
is his armor fat or is he fat
damn get annihilated kid
owned
ow
flame of the fel god
dope
that was good pull though okay
dragon lord sucks so much no dude
plastics is so cool
who the [ __ ] is a don is it aiden or a
don probably either one it doesn't even
matter let's check our list checking
lists
we've killed a don
i think that's it wait no we killed uh
omen killer
nice
where's the godskin noble out here dog
we could uh actually we're right next to
latena let's go there
why can't he kill patches because we
want to do his questline
i i really like plasti-du
sax it's definitely one of the best
dragon fights i've ever ever done
am i missing the entrance here
i didn't think it was this far
i could be wrong though
i was wrong
flappy butt flaps was a great fight
indeed
speed running and 100
that's gonna be tough
i think we have a bloodhound knight down
here right i think yeah
bruh
three
yeah just don't copy pasta dragon fight
and then it's a good fight
i think the you know the different
elemental dragons that you fight
throughout the play throughout the game
it's just annoying
like the magic one the frost one
i think ag heal
in the lake
right where you start is awesome but the
other ones are just like
it's the same thing with just like a
different skin and different colored
abilities
you know
all right what up bro
we got no stagger i see
i'm dead
i died
oh this moveset is so hard
nice
i forgot he does that
i'm stuck in a rock
oh
bang
bang
just found out the virgin and ryers
kidnaps you and brings you to some place
like the big man in bloodborne yup
takes you to volcano manor we talked
about that earlier
it's crazy on melania it got a rot
goddess
doesn't inflict rod as much as the uh
random dragon
shrewded
true
fell
tarnished what do you want
i told the all-hearing brute that i
possess no such medallion
or have you come to take more from me
wasn't my other half oh i didn't talk to
old man yet did i
i gotta i gotta go up here
or i gotta go here first that's fine
no i should have
rig i hit the wrong thing
i'm an idiot
a big big stupid head
[Music]
i need to look into these flowers and
butterflies that could be a lore video
100
please no
dear me please leave me be
i haven't a clue
no secrets lie with me not a one
oh please leave me be
i played this game way too much wait
then
you're not one of them
well
what a relief
we think so engraved
oh
goodness me
i
am almost
an albanoric
as you can see
we're finished
the whole village is finished
the coast mongers have destroyed
everything
no one that remains i should have turned
my lantern on
i beg you so we could see this guy would
you look after this medallion medallion
i must keep it out of the cursements
hands
and if you should meet the young albino
reckletena
then please give it to her
why does every npc have to die
is this your first souls game
that leads to the city
everyone dies
everybody
dear
dies
it is needed
to fulfill her purpose
my legs will soon fade i haven't
declined
my life
alas
this
is the immovable i did see that
mumishi
when he said he wants to research more
into it i was like
i'm gonna do that
i like that theory
and
rip
how would you rank the souls games
i've been thinking about this
i really have recently
it's really hard to choose i i think
eldon ring
is the culmination of everything that
they've they've made and worked on over
the since they started making souls
games
i think it makes sense for eldon ring to
be at the top i think elden ring is the
best game they've ever made
it's the best experience i've had in
gaming overall
i would i would rank them
elden ring
bloodborne
sakiro
dark souls 3 dark souls 1
demon souls dark souls 2.
that's my ranking i think
kyle thanks for the five bucks man and
the cute little
super thanks
bravo
that's so cute thank you man i
appreciate you
thank you thank you
that that's how i would rank them i
really would i think it would be elden
ring bloodborne
sakiro i i think sakiro is better than
dark souls 3. i love dark souls 3 though
yeah eldon ring bloodborne sakura dark
souls 3
dark souls 1 demon souls dark souls 2.
i have not played king's field so i
can't can't say that
it is extremely hard to
balance an open world game
so i think they definitely are
struggling a bit in the uh in the in the
balancing issues of this game but that
can always be that can always be tweets
you know
if you donate a million dollars jake
will personally kiss you on the lips
with consent
yes i would
nobody here has a million dollars so
no shot
i think dark souls 3 is better hero and
bloodborne simply because of the boss
fights in the music
yeah i honestly i think when it comes to
ranking these games it's it's pretty
much just preference
of like
boss types that you like aesthetics
atmosphere
and bloodborne just has that victorian
setting that i just dig dude
i dig it
you that one looks super weird
it's got more runes
a little 210 banger okay
eldon ring bussy
yeah it's i just this this is this is
the game
i don't think you get it gets much
better than this
oh hello i'm back told the all-hearing
brute already that i possess no such
medallion or have you come to take more
from me i have not played that demo now
show the secret medallion
do you speak true
so old albus entrusted his medallion
team you want to pet joy for a million
dollars i have no choice oh that's yeah
sure this was his dying will
let's try again
i'm lieutenant
an albanoric the same as old albus my
apologies for my course words earlier i
presume the worst
seeing that you're another tarnished
like that all-hearing brute
i hope that you will forgive me
elden ring is my first soulsborne i
don't know if i want to play any others
because it won't be as good
go in if you want to play those games go
in expecting it not to be like eldon
ring
because it won't be
it won't
it's a it's a totally different
experience but with the same
it's hard to put it it's hard to put go
in expecting something different and you
will enjoy those games
absolutely
if you really like eldon ring play dark
souls 3.
that
that's probably as close as it gets to
elden ring is dark souls 3.
um
the medallion's better off in your hands
anyway would you consider doing me a
great service
i must go back
there is something i must do
even if i must say farewell to my wolf
lobo
will you show me the way
to the land of nicholas haleg tree
if you accept absolutely i will gladly
apprise you
of the whereabouts of the medallions of
the half
do you think elden ring will have more
than one dlc
dark souls 3 had three dlcs so yes
absolutely it will
has dark souls 3 been remastered
or you mean dark souls
i don't think the remastered is worth it
it's not very good
for dark souls one
they say the other half of them but like
why not it's beyond the forbidden lands
north of the tree
in castles yeah the s3 had three dlcs
no it only had two
you're right
it was uh the painted world and then the
ring city
i don't know why i thought there was one
before that yeah there was only two
that's my bad
but yeah elden ring
you guys you guys know how successful
this game has been this game has been
stupidly
stupidly successful like
this game has gone way above and beyond
what i ever thought a souls game could
be
absolutely i need to talk to her again i
think
then i suppose it's time
farewell lobo
my faithful wolf
my better half
i will go with the tarnished oh she's
actually petting him
i didn't notice that
oh
rip lobo
when needed
and i will fight at your side
yeah it was 13 million copies in the
first three months which outsold call of
duty vanguard
uh what they sold in a year and they did
it in three months if you're out selling
call of duty
you are mainstream success
ronnie or
no
no a lot of people don't even know who
gwendolyn is
how you do that
i just did that bro
i just did it
all right do we go
okay we beat bloodhound night i think
that's it since i last checked this
which is
yeah
where are you
bloodhound night
is it not on this list or any of the
lakes
[Music]
it's not even here
rig
oh well
couldn't even couldn't even check it off
you play any souls likes i don't know
what those are so no
is it possible to level as little as you
can of course
people have beaten this game uh rune
level one
are you a melanoma maniac or a ronnie
enjoyer we actually did a poll earlier
that showed that everyone's a ronnie
simp
it was like six seventy to thirty
percent
all right let's keep exploring we can go
to the where is it
how is this a boss fight
i'm confused
um okay
anyway let's just keep going let's keep
exploring let's keep doing our thing
i thought i saw something there okay
what else can we do what else can we do
we can go see ronnie can't we
we should go in here actually
we can get some uh really good
we get we can beat a boss
and we can get a bell bearing
it's going to help us out
oh [ __ ] i always forget about that you
exist
i always forget about this guy
that scared me who on earth are you
hmm never mind but tell me if you know
would you the whereabouts of the hidden
house of those despicable fiends the
recusants who hunt their fellow
tarnished the house of hosler was
written in blood
and i refuse to let the insult stand
the tale of house oslo is told in blood
i dialos swear to deliver the message
thing she got messed up bro
they laid hands upon my servant lanyard
and i'm the tale of hi
you know what this guy is chat
he's emotional
he needs to calm
down
agreed
way
too emotional
yeah he's kind of stupid
he's gullible
he's just kind of a kind of a [ __ ]
knight finlay or black knife quiche
that's not a bad one
yeah finlay carried melania basically
across
the continent
back to the haley from caled back to the
haley tree
that's kind of insane
you a bug
i hate bugs
hey yo what up bro
you guys think i could beat the godskin
in the volcano manor
i don't know if i could
i find that fight to be really tough
where'd he go where'd it go there we go
no palm
no
that's pain dude
you'll live though
yeah i don't i think that would be
extremely difficult to do
i was looking to chat and realized i
didn't land on where i wanted to land
and i got scared
is this a no cheese run oh we will
cheese if we want
this is a run where we do whatever we
want
oh god i shouldn't have even hit you
stay
ow
okay that did not protect me that did
not protect me get me out
okay we're pretty much just going to the
bottom we don't we don't want to mess
around with any of these guys
we want to get out of here
we're going to grab their stuff and
we're gonna go
[Music]
he doesn't have anything
lol you miss
nerd lol
god platforming oh
smithing stone three
somber three
why you gotta stream while i'm at work
um youtube tells me that my viewers
or
yeah my subscribers
are mostly
on youtube between like
10 00
in the morning to like three in the
afternoon
youtube gives you all the analytics so i
just listen to youtube it's a solid
you do a vid on vary
i mean probably eventually
i'm taking a little break from making
videos right now
well i'm dead aren't i
[Music]
i'm out of here
you're always on after three hey i just
listened to youtube man
youtube tells me different
yeah i could depend on like time zones
and everything like that
i died at this jump more times than the
boss same i i've gotten good at that
jump
i could do a bit on bari but i'm doing
i'm doing a very small break from making
videos and i just kind of want to hang
out and stream
because
i mean with with all this reddit [ __ ]
that's been going on like every time i
post a video i just get [ __ ] nervous
that people are just gonna hate raid me
for
no [ __ ] reason so
it's not fun when that happens
so i'm just gonna i'm taking a small
break
i'm dead
i'm alive
i'm fine
very small break
mental health very important
okay let me take this
and streaming's been fun on here so i'm
just gonna keep doing it
okay
i already got that one
how's it doing right now the newest one
is doing amazing
i haven't checked in in a day or two but
i it was over a hundred thousand views
last time i checked
so super good
look at all these resources man
this place is a gold mine
reddit mobs need to touch some grass
definitely
i am uh not a fan of reddit to say the
least now
there's a lot of stones in this cave
okay this should be easy
watch me die
you gotta break that armor
oh that was fast
oh that delay on that swing is just
absurd
reddit's where you can be falsely
accused of stuff that's what i'm saying
i've been falsely accused twice the
first time it happened
um they were
probably the worst people i've ever
dealt with in my life like they were
just [ __ ] instantaneous like you're a
piece of [ __ ] you're a fraud you're
you're [ __ ] like i don't believe
anything you say you're like they just
immediately
hate rated me right away
the second time it happened
which by the way both of them were on
gideon videos for whatever reason gideon
is just gatekeeped by people
the most recent one they were extremely
nice and understanding
uh and they were like oh
yeah you're right and this and then they
just stopped
so i've had two completely different
experiences that are still stressful as
hell
so i'm just taking a small break
[Music]
oh that's one way to get over here huh i
didn't know that
i guess gideon fanboys exist
certain enemies are vulnerable to a
certain type of type of damage yes so
like those crystal girls would have been
easier if i just had a blunt weapon or
like a heavy weapon
i have katanas so i just bounce off them
so i have to use my ash aboard even do
anything
so yeah
no bunny did not get keep it all
i don't like talking to these chicks
they talk too much love your orbits
well thank you aaron
eden yeager
thanks for the five bucks man i
appreciate that thank you
and i'm glad you like him
don't stream bro somebody i'm on reddit
might have already done an eldering
stream
dude exactly i mean
i've gotten a lot of good advice on
stuff like this from uh
other
big youtubers actually like
uh smoketown talk to me about it
um there were a couple
a couple others on twitter um like a
month ago
that
were super nice and they're like hey
this is just kind of what happens just
deal with it however you can and just
ignore it it's
they just do it on purpose you know
i already made a video on reddit so you
can go watch that if you want
i'm just trying to think of where to go
next
he is a gideon in my opinion is a
[ __ ] snake man
uh we should go get the other part of
the deck to smedalian um i actually
don't even think we got the first one
did we did we go in here
let me check and see if i have it
yep so now we need to go to caleb and
get the other one
which we could do we could run in there
and get it
real quick
yeah we got to go to caled
well actually i need to go through here
anyway to beat the magma worm we should
just go through here
let's let's just do that
let's just do that
reddit has two sides bad and good i
haven't seen the good side yet
not not a singular time have i seen the
good side
so
i haven't even been on the website
recently
not a fan
i have not heard of dark tarp tark yet
not yet
god damn it i'm late
you're never late if you're here
two-handed grip perry viable or shield
it's like the king on parry
uh if you're good at pairing
right we gotta go this way
let's get it
[Music]
you know what you know what's the
funniest part about
this the last thing i'm going to say
about the reddit guy
the reddit thing
his his entire goal because he said it
in his own comments of his thread
he said my goal
is to make jake lose subscribers
for
because i think he did this certain
thing
or what he posted on reddit
that was his whole goal
when he posted that i had 3 000
subscribers
and we're getting close to 50k
and that was within a month
so he did not do what he set out to do
he said i want to make this whole thing
public so jake will lose subscribers
nice job
yeah i need to go to the grandma recipes
next thing i know i'm gonna get a
copyright strike because i was following
along
uh making cookies and i'm gonna get
copyright struck by grandma
i won't even be recording anything i
won't even make a video she'll just show
up at my house and say you can't make
the same cookies as me
who's the hater i mean you can go watch
the reddit video if you want i made it
like two weeks ago
three weeks ago
what build you going for don't know yet
we're just going double katana
we're gonna get some cool weapons that
chat wants me to play with and i can
respect with ronald
yeah a silver play button would be
really cool that would be lit
that's the goal
my goal is by the end of the year to get
100 000 subscribers
and we've been going off the last month
two months
so i think right now is the perfect time
to take a little tiny
tiny vacation just stream for a week and
then we'll move on with some more lore
videos
do i have no not yet okay
does anyone else hate the magma worm
bosses i think they're trash
trash
damn kyle you're getting you're getting
roasted right now bro
the lore of them is dope okay maybe i
need to look in it more i just don't
like fighting them i don't like fighting
them at all
sometimes they just charge over and over
and over again
this is annoying
i can probably go upgrade my weapons as
well
oh
yeah tree spirits and magna worms are
not fun at all
i need to lower chat on the screen a
little bit don't i
aesthetically it's bothering me
that it's not lined up
[Music]
leave me be
i ain't done none but a thing
morningstar beasts
hey i like those
i don't know why though
these games are so preference
like one person can absolutely love a
boss while another one just despises it
i think that's great
i don't that's not a stone so we're
gonna move on
this one explodes because gideon trapped
it
very nice very nice very nice
instead of becoming dragons they turn
into these magma spitting belly-crawling
abominations
nice
that's creepy
that is creepy dude
i haven't thought about that too
critically i think they are actually bad
morning star
beasts
i already read that one
yeah morning i i don't know there there
are some certain bosses that aren't
super fun but they're okay
i don't have too much
i don't have too many gripes
with many enemies or bosses in the game
i thought melania's waterfowl dance was
such [ __ ] for a long time but now
i've gotten used to it
and i kind of
melania's boss fight has grown on me a
lot
like i actually enjoy it
now that i know how to dodge [ __ ]
but for a while it was
just dealing with that waterfowl dance
was
awful
dragon communion next story behind them
big ass dragon king bosses are cool
yeah there's there's so many videos i
could make i just need to pick one
i shouldn't have picked that
there's one over here two over here
stop singing grandma
don't hit
me yep once i learned you can throw
consumables at melania she she really
grew on me a lot more
you can just chuck a bottle at her and
she'll stop the waterfowl
i think i think the fight's fair
come on
yep depends on your play styles your
builds
your skill level
obviously
a lot factors into somebody's enjoyment
with the boss
and that's totally fine
that's the way they intended it
bye bye
before i go in here let me um let me
upgrade
agreed that's why the game is so good
there's
so many different ways to play it so i i
find it weird that some people oh yeah
we're in trouble here um
that some people will just like only
play elden ring once and they're like
yeah it's boring now like try a
different build
there's definitely stuff you haven't
found
and get on
but uh
i think it's impossible to only play
this game once
and
by the way the clinging bone is terrible
well
i took you for no match i had your arms
lay out your arms then
that's pretty decent
i need five smithing stone twos and a
smithing stone three let's see if we can
buy some
have a good day infamous
first time playing the game i freaked
out thinking the game was broken when
the guy invaded
no no no
exactly as intended
one
i only need one
oh [ __ ]
wait i need
i would say my highest point
in elden rings still was um
the radon fight stage two of radon oh my
god already no matter
it's just
fantastic
watching streams after work feels like
heaven retail is hell
i've i've worked in retail i was uh i
worked in the golf industry which is
pretty much retail
it's [ __ ] horrible man i i i feel you
may not be as crazy as some retail
places but man
retail sucks
oh yeah inch is dead
i wish they would have done more with
incha
they really didn't do [ __ ] with her
with him it's a it's a guy the heck
there's summon science out here
what
black guard
who the hell is this
look at this guy
great horned
tragic
what
oh what the why'd you do that
[Music]
i didn't know they were here
yo what up casual greeting
what up man okay let's get it
that looks like an absolute tank
and she probably is a puppet of gideon
but that is true
uh the art for the thumbnail is in the
description
i thought he's swinging his tail
now
i hate these fights bro
why am i doing no damage
we are doing no damage
there we go
mom
can't hit him here
it's struggling to bleed
we'll take it
whoa
why do i do no damage to this thing
oh who died black guard died
oh come on dude
jesus
oh god
thank you jesus
jeez
okay we'll take it
usually that boss is like really easy
but that that took a lot
all right
made it to the altis plateau
that's pretty good
macar more like dead
true
because i'm not
cosplaying i don't even know who jet
stream sam is
wish eldon ring had tail weapons
isn't it
a tail that i get
no it's a sword kind of looks like a
tail though
oh [ __ ] you want to do radon now
we're done at level
what am i doing
47
47.
once you hit the top go through the
water and hit the cave
baby rattle weapon
baby rattle
hey melano
oh cut off the tail yeah yeah yeah
tree
is close
only a little further till the foot of
the earth tree
and the accord is fulfilled
it takes me back
i was born
at the foot of the earth tree
ham cake thighs
nice so now
everything is lost to me
i
have to ascertain for myself
the reason for which i live
burned
and bodiless
hmm
okay
uh we were just here so it's uh the
ruins ruined precipice
you can go this all the way through here
and then like up some ladders to get to
where we just were if you've never been
there before
best elden ring waifu we already did a
poll earlier everyone voted ronnie
ronnie ronnie ronnie
it's all about ronnie
i just run past this guy
you don't get anything for fighting him
and he just disappears halfway through
degenerates
i'm not gonna lie chad if i had to
choose i'd pick nephili
nephili lose just my type
nfloo is
nice
nice with it
[Music]
tomboy girlfriend
hey i like girls that work out
are
athletic you know their independence i'm
a big fan of independent girls
big fan big fan
like they don't need no man
but
they want a man like me okay let's go to
kaelin i think uh caleb
kale it is the time it is now the time
for caleb i think
well
we about to find out
have a good one yoda
crush your head with those thighs
i mean
hey
okay now you guys are just horny
all right
if you want to do it on now then you
need to trigger for selen's quest if you
don't you can't return there to do the
trigger
uh
should should we go through ronnie's
area first
probably
back over her
probably yeah we probably should yeah
oh she she's a lady man she's just
strong
i like strong women
that's my type man
that's my type
ronnie's just kind of mean
and melon is kind of naggy
oh we need to go to selling not celibus
let's do that first i just want to grab
that obviously i wasn't totally like off
my rocker there okay
uh right
here
puppet gosh
oh my god can we talk about that can we
talk about this real quick
how many of you did i if you guys
watched my last lore video on gideon how
many of you guys did i trick
my whole goal was to have everyone be
like
is the gideon line at the end real
no it's not real it's a [ __ ] parody
i trolled a little bit
just a little bit
what
okay
you need to grab comment azure first to
talk to selling
yeah i get you guys yeah it's not real
check check the pin comment
a lot of comments were like dude it's
not real bro
it's not real dawg
i'm like i know
i love it it it really farms some
comments man it really did young
apprentice
first things first
you are a tadpole when it comes to magic
infantile i found your sex dungeon
without the legs to walk
so to become a sorcerer first
you must face your ignorance
now
shall we start learning
first you must face your ignorance
you wish to continue very well
can't i talk to her about her sex
dungeon
not yet
did you stick her in a jar
and fill your tarnished seed
i i really like how many people thought
it was real
and so many people who were like dude
it's not real
because the guy who did the voice acting
for that
is so or the impersonation of him did it
so perfectly
did you
stick her in a jar
imagine what she can do with those four
arms
to your
tarnished tackle
uh check the the pin comment if you want
to see who did it
in that video
it does sound like something jojar
martin would write though a hundred a
hundred thousand percent
[Music]
i play
other than eldon ring i play apex
legends with my friends
i like apex
how
george rr martin's a horn dog
he writes good stories man
how many times have you finished the
game
i've gotten every ending
but i've never tried to go through the
game 100 in one playthrough
ah
fast doggy
well george rr martin did not write the
ending to game of thrones
the show
they completely just
those two idiots who wrote the freaking
uh
season seven season eight of game of
thrones or
i think they should never get work again
they ruined game of thrones
and it was not what george rrardon
george r.r martin wrote
hang it
whoa
i think the whole show's worth it just
game of thrones is worth watching
the ending will just piss you off
whoa
easy peasy
hold the door
hold the door
hold the door
for this playthrough i'm going to let
chat decide what ending we do
do you watch anime
kinda
a little bit
like i watched attacked on titan
i've seen all of naruto
i like naruto
i watched all of hunter hunter and
didn't like it
didn't like it
i've seen death note i like death note
death note's cool
all right let's fight you just get you
out of the way
why is everyone talking about berserk
i've seen it all over twitter
what the heck is berserk
okay
now
bye bye
it's a manga that dark souls is heavily
based on oh
okay cool
well wiring uh a bunch of reddit uh
why aren't a bunch of reddit
berserk fans uh copyrighting miyazaki
for making elden rings so much like
berserk
where did it go i don't know it just
[ __ ] off
we see it at the end of ronnie's
questline
the anime sucks though
oh
then oh okay
i won't watch it then
because they have class
ah
long manga that launched in 89
jesus oh the author died okay that's
kind of sad
i really like death note yes i would
recommend watching it
irani oh
chad it's your wife
it it's your wife i believe i said my
name was rena sip foreign
it pleases me to see torrent hail and
hearty but tarnished hail and hearty
what business has thou here
i have no memory of ink in the in
invitation
no reason no reason in particular though
claims intriguing
then may happs fate hath steered thee to
this reunion
will thou enter into my service
i am the witch ronnie
i stole death long ago
and search now for the dark path the
youtube video quality is so shitty and
the whole of it wait really and rid the
world of all that came before
well
has that roused thy interest
sure i see
a choice well made
thou heard a rare sword
not many would have accepted the offer
but i require as much of those under my
command
i anticipate good work from me
it's so easy to join any faction in this
game they're just like do you want to
join and they go
oh sure
and they're like i bet then i ask we
proceed with haste
there is in my service
a half-woven warrior
by the name of blythe
i would have thee join him in searching
for the hidden treasure of nocron
the eternal city we are not a fan of
twitch here
take from him the particulars i streamed
on twitch for four years and they will
thou find eg
garbage platform
encelavus
preceptor in the source yeah who else
are they gonna ask that's true
probably surprising that i'm even here
feel secure in gaining from them we have
not gone to volcano manor yet now
i'm sure the others will be doing just
the same
okay
speak without needs
now we gotta go talk to everybody
why is twitch so bad
do i want to get into that
i'll i'll give you guys one
one little thing that i think summarizes
my feelings of twitch
all right
yes i'm american
i streamed on twitch for four years
i got partnered on twitch and i
accumulated 20 000 followers on there
playing rocket league for the most part
mostly rocky
coaching on there everything doing
thousands of dollars of giveaways
for uh tournaments in rocket league and
everything like that did that for years
got 20 000 followers
the only reason i got those followers
was not because i was streaming on
twitch
but because i
advertised my twitch channel on tiktok
for probably around two years
i got
20
million views on tick tock 20 million
and i got about 20 000 followers to come
over to twitch i averaged like
at peak
like 300 viewers
and then by the time that i stopped
playing if once i stopped playing rocket
league
i had one viewer
partner
partnered on twitch i had one viewer and
it was kyle in the chat
in one month on youtube
we're almost at 50 000 subscribers
it took one month with no outside
advertising
twitch does not promote their creators
at all unless they're at the top
if you are not one of the top streamers
on twitch they do not care
they will never help you
you were on their sometimes trip
but yeah
with one month of hard work on youtube i
have
completely outdone what took me four
years on twitch
so that's why i don't like twitch
not a fan of twitch
well at least youtube has an algorithm
which is just pray that people watch you
oh so you were the one
lady rani has explained everything
again i am eegee
the karyan royal family's dedicated
blacksmith and lady rani's war counselor
i am told that you are searching for
knockron with blithe
i will give you whatever guidance i can
and pray for your success
also
youtube chat
has been
exponentially better than twitch
exponentially better than twitch has
been
i mean kyle remember how many people did
we ban a day on twitch it was insane
it it was crazy so many people
were just toxic
douchebags have you forgotten glad to
have you in the service of mistress
ronnie joy's fantastic paul thanks for
asking getting right to business
i'm still in limb grave
the eternal city of noah it's blood my
summer at the bottom of this land
i'm planning to go below through the
yeah we'd ban 10 to 15 people a day i
can't find the road to knock ron from
there
we're not as horny
yeah
knocking yeah
through the well in the midst
see if i can't find the road to knock
run don't and you guys are better at
chatting you guys are better at talking
about the game
which constantly wanted me to talk about
my own life for some reason
i see
you must you guys care about the game
yes you smelly poopoo burnhole
does not have an instagram she's on mine
though i don't know what it is the
mistress sees in a provincial tarnished
like you
but since we have the misfortune of
serving the same lady
i ask that you kindly try not to drag us
all down with you god i hate this guy
i mean you guys haven't you guys noticed
that about the top streamers on twitch
the the parasocial relationships that
they have with their streamer and their
viewers are
concerning to me
joy's my dog
um
like
they really really really like want to
have a very very close-knit relationship
with you where you you guys on youtube
give a [ __ ] but it's not
like uh so parasocial like it is on
twitch it's super weird over there i
reside in another tower close by
come and pay me a visit
should you wish to be of actual service
to mistress ronnie his hat is
to me i wouldn't waste my time on the
likes of you
but who am i to stand against the wishes
of my lady
okay bye
some guy in reddit said he trademark
sylvia sylvus's dialogue
i don't doubt it
i don't doubt it bro
i do have to get off here in a little
bit guys because uh
it's my parents anniversary today and
i'm taking them out for
like a lunch dinner
gonna go see my sister as well
god damn it i didn't talk to them enough
hey so i actually own elden ring
if you go on to twitch the people there
tend to get super personal we care about
you but we didn't come but we didn't
come to watch the stream about you
talking about your life i agree
you came here to watch elden ring and
have some like
me commentate
my apologies
for the misleading words i'm 27. my
parents have been married 30 years today
let alone service to lady rami was in
your faith 30 years for one should have
seen it
but i did not
do forgive me
my fellow
let us give all that we can of ourselves
together
for lady ronnie
my favorite weapons uh rivers of blood
i'm a katana fan boy i'm going below
through the well in the midst okay i
definitely talk to you enough
what about you
thank you guys
i'll let them know you said that
my uh my parents are in chat sometimes
you should you wish to be of actual
service if it were up but who
okay that's gotta be it
youtube has been extremely friendly for
the most part
at least in live streams comments have
been uh you know sometimes they're
pretty pretty pretty mean
but
live streaming it's been great
i could have voiced reichard
and you know it
oh she's already asleep
okay
chat
i'm gonna end it there for today
it's a special day for my parents i want
to take them out
take him out to a nice restaurant it'll
be nice but um
i think i'll stream again tomorrow
i'm just gonna i'm gonna stream this
week
can i see how it's going
um
take a little break from what making
videos for like a week and then we'll
get back to it i just want to stream i
enjoy streaming here it's it's been a
lot of fun
so thank you for that appreciate all the
support
um
check out all the stuff in the
description if you want to support more
it i really appreciate it if you go and
check those out
um but we'll be back tomorrow doing the
same thing we'll just continue from this
spot
so
you guys all take care today i
appreciate every single one of you like
i said
um
yeah check everything out in the
description that's it guys
thanks for being here we'll be back
tomorrow probably tomorrow or the next
day we'll see but
peace and love thank you so much
see y'all later
bye bye bye bye bye